this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their awesome all
in one platform
through the link in the description
below more about them in a bit
the invention of the automobile changed
america and the world irrevocably it did
so in a way that few other inventions
across human history really have
the car transformed the way people lived
as the very landscape we reside in
transformed to accommodate its needs
commerce entertainment and
the relationship between people and
cities were all changed throughout the
20th century and people began to
question whether we as a society needed
cities at all or if we should replace it
with
endless suburban sprawl at the center of
all of this was robert moses
moses might not be a widely known name
outside of his native new york city but
he is in fact one of the most important
figures in
not just new york history but in
american history though he never held
elected office at one point he was the
most powerful man in all of new york
state a
tireless public official who built
bridges roads and tunnels all the while
not seeming to care that much about the
people who used them he was america's
biggest advocate for the transformed
city based
around cars and their needs and he did
whatever he had to in order to
facilitate his vision
for the modern new york at the beginning
of his long career moses was celebrated
as new york's master builder
constructing a number of the city's most
important transportation
and civic landmarks helping to lift the
city out at the depths of the great
depression
but by the end of it and in the decades
after his death his reputation was
tainted by allegations that he behaved
as an autocrat running
roughshod over the people in his quest
for power destroying countless
neighborhoods and replacing them with
highways or sterile public housing
blocks that may have been
efficient but tore the heart and soul
out of the old city in the process
this is the story of a man who proved
the old adage that
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions especially
when you pave the road yourself
it's hard to overstate how disastrous
the great depression was to the united
states throughout the 1920s the
country's economy had seemed to have
no ceiling which made it all the more
shocking when the stock market crash of
1929 precipitated a general economic
downturn
unlike anything ever seen before or
since in 1929 the united states had
around 2 million unemployed workers
by 1932 there were a little under 2
million unemployed people
in new york city alone as banks failed
factories shut down international trade
slowed to a trickle
and countless millions lost their jobs
homes and possessions
new york was america's financial heart
so it only made sense that the
depression hit the city hardest of all
central park was home to a shanty town
called hooverville full of desperate
homeless people who had nowhere else to
go into the disaster step to the city's
newly elected
mayor fiorello laguardia a brash
excitable little man who loved the city
and the people who lived there
able to speak multiple languages and a
tireless candidate for reform from the
time he took office in 1934 he worked to
dismantle the old system
of patronage the tammany hall machine
that had
effectively ruled new york since the
time of the civil war and
in the first years of the depression
were more notable for siphoning off most
of the federal relief dollars for
themselves than anything else
once he was done reforming the civil
services he sought to use the federal
money pouring out of washington as part
of franklin roosevelt's new deal
to rebuild new york's economy through
massive public works projects
putting people to work while providing
essential upgrades to new york's
crumbling infrastructure
in this he found a perfect partner in
robert moses
robert moses was born on december the
18th 1888 in new haven connecticut
growing up two blocks from
the prestigious yale university which he
would eventually attend
his father was a successful businessman
who moved his family to new york city in
1897 beginning a lifelong connection
with the big apple he was exceptionally
well educated getting his bachelor's
from yale his masters from oxford and
his phd from colombia and
he took a keen interest in the politics
of new york city's reform movement he
caught the attention of
al smith elected new york governor in
and a passionate advocate for reform in
spite of his origins within tammany hall
in 1924 smith created the long island
state park commission and named robert
moses's chairman
moses went immediately to work his
definition of parks grew to include
parkways roadways filled with
plenty of green space and plant life
along the route the idea was that at a
time when most people drove automobiles
purely for pleasure
that its parkways should be a pleasure
to drive on as a destination for
his parkway on long island he chose
jones beach one of
long island's barrier islands facing the
atlantic ocean moses led a team that
extensively remade the island into a
state
park that was the perfect summer getaway
for new york city residents
by now the car was transforming from a
rich man's toy to an affordable means of
transportation for middle-class
americans thanks to henry ford's
assembly line
new yorkers flocked to jones beach using
the newly constructed parkways
this success propelled robert moses to
the forefront of new york politics being
briefly considered as a political
candidate in his own right before mayor
laguardia appointed him as
new york city's parks commissioner in
1934. their first project together was
to renovate the central park zoo which
had been allowed to deteriorate so badly
that
men with shotguns were stationed at the
entrance in case the animals escaped
from the rusty old cages moses used
works project administration wpa funds
and
workers from the federal government to
build playgrounds and swimming pools
across new
york but it was a project that had
nothing to do with parks that made his
reputation as the master builder of new
york a project that would become known
as the mighty tri-borough
there had been plans as early as 1916 to
build a tri-burro bridge that connected
manhattan the bronx and queens at the
confluence of the harlem and east rivers
that separated them the city
broke grounds on the project on october
25 1929 which unfortunately
also happened to be the day after the
beginning of the stock market crash that
triggered the depression construction
proceeded at a snail's pace until it
hold it all together by 1932 people in
new york have begun to refer to the
project as the bridge to nowhere in 1934
the state legislature created the
tribara bridge authority
a public benefit corporation that was
empowered to issue bonds
in other words borrow money to finance
the construction of the bridge which
would be
repaid with the revenue from the tolls
charged once it opened robert moses
became the chairman of the tba in april
of that year and from that point on was
the driving force behind the project
construction began in earnest in 1935
and it was a massive project employing 5
000 workers at the bridge site itself
supported by many times that number that
worked to provide the raw materials and
logistics needed to
bring those materials to the side
building the bridge would eventually
encompass 31 million man-hours of work
from
people in 20 different states as well as
60 million dollars
almost a billion dollars in today's
money the triborough bridge was
dedicated in july 1936 in a ceremony
attended by president roosevelt mayor
laguardia and
the governor of new york herbert lehmann
the bridge actually a series of three
bridges was lauded as a modern marvel of
engineering and even today is a vital
transportation link between the three
boroughs
carrying almost 100 000 vehicles across
it every day robert moses was hailed
as a hero of the city the master builder
one of new york's most
important public servants what he did
next went unnoticed by almost everyone
outside
of the inner circle of inner politics
the idea behind public benefit
corporations is for them to be temporary
once the cost of construction is met by
toll revenue
they're supposed to be shut down but
robert moses had no intention of
shutting down the tba
he still chaired instead he used the
money triba raised as a steady source of
funding for further public works
projects or personally controlled by him
no one realized at the time but the
tri-borough would become the foundation
of an empire now if you'd like to build
a foundation for your own empire
you're going to start with a great
website and that of course
is where our longtime friends at
squarespace come in you know what's
great about summer vacation
time off a little bit of r r it's the
perfect time to spend lying on the beach
or
in the park thinking about what next
project you want to start fortunately
squarespace gives you every possible
tool you might want to make that dream
into a reality
whether it's a small business a sports
blog a creative portfolio or just a page
of dank memes it doesn't matter if you
can dream it you can build it with
squarespace
you're looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like well use
one of their quick and
beautiful templates to make a website
that's fresh and for you
or maybe you're more of a hands-on
person you've got lots of opinions and
ideas about what exactly your site
should look like while squarespace gives
you all the customization options you
could ever want with no updates no
patches no technical bs to worry about
once you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing with the
colors
there are so many extra features that
squarespace provides that your website
can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member only
areas analytics commercial options
travel
customer support everything you really
need is in
one place so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big
or small if it involves a website it's
got to be the squarespace right now you
can go to squarespace.com for a free
trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash buy
graphics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain now let's get back to building
the big apple
moses and laguardia did the best they
could to drag their city out of the
depths of the depression throughout the
rest of the 1930s in 1939 new york
hosted the world's fair
a massive event that drew 44 million
visitors through its gates
though the hopeful message of the dream
of tomorrow was dampened somewhat by the
outbreak of the second world war just
four months after it opened the design
and construction of the site was
directed by moses who was now considered
the authority on any public building
project in the metropolitan area he had
big plans for the future of new york but
those had to be shelved when the united
states was finally dragged into the
global conflict
by the japanese attack on pearl harbor
in december of 1941.
everything was put on pause for the
duration of the war as
america transformed its empire economy
into building war material by the time
the war ended in 1945 the world had
changed america
emerged from the conflict as the most
powerful and prosperous country on earth
the centre of what would become a global
economy the huge factories that had
built planes and tanks could
now be turned over to civilian use and
before long refrigerators washing
machines vacuum cleaners and especially
cars were
rolling off the assembly line across the
country it also marked the end of an era
as mayor laguardia retired after three
terms in office at the end of 1945.
he was exhausted and already sick with
the cancer that would claim his life in
september of 1947.
may laguardia and robert moses had not
liked each other personally but they had
formed a remarkable partnership over the
course of 12 years that
had accomplished a lot of good for the
city without laguardia around to serve
as a counterweight to moses the personal
power that the latter had been steadily
accumulating for the last decade was now
completely unchecked the influence he
now wielded was on full display in 1946
when
moses was able to persuade the newly
formed united nations to choose new york
as the location of their headquarters
moses oversaw construction of the
magnificent building that is still in
use today as the
center of world diplomacy it would prove
to be the last uncontroversial thing
that robert moses ever did
one of moses most prolific skills was
his ability to write his own bills
convincing the state legislature to
pass them into law without really
reading the fine print which usually
enhanced moses's own power to a degree
that most people would consider alarming
in a democracy for instance in 1946
moses convinced the new mayor william
o'dwyer to
appoint him the city's construction
coordinator something that
hadn't existed until moses decided that
it should what no one realized until
after the appointment was already made
was that hidden in the pages of the job
description was a clause that made the
construction coordinator the official
representative of new york city in
washington d.c from now on
all requests from new york to the
federal government had to go through
robert moses
meanwhile moses used the toll revenues
from the triborough bridge and other
bridge authorities that he had created
and operated over the years
to control vast sums of money this freed
him from the power
of the purse he no longer needed to ask
the city or the state of new york for
money for his public works projects he
was not beholden to the will of the
voters since he wasn't an elected
official
and he was so well connected in the
business and political community that no
mayor could hope to remove him from his
post now that he had made himself
arguably the most powerful figure in the
city
he was free to pursue all of his
projects without interference the master
builder had a vision for the future of
his kingdom and new york would
never be the same again
[Music]
in the years following the end of world
war ii it had become apparent that the
infrastructure of american cities was
woefully inadequate to
meet modern needs in the span of a
single generation the car had gone from
being a plaything of the wealthy to an
essential part of every middle-class
american's life the rise of the car had
dispelled one of the longest-held
notions of american life that you needed
to live
close to where you worked now that
commuting to and from work via car was
possible
those who could afford it began to move
from cities into the newly built suburbs
the new american dream was to own a
single family house with
a backyard and a white picket fence but
to get back and forth commuters
needed to use roads roads that were too
small for the amount of traffic that was
now flooding them what was needed
was highways huge limited access
roadways that could transport cars at
high speeds to and from cities
robert moses was one of the first to
recognize this and was perhaps the most
passionate advocate for what is today
known
as car culture he was determined to
transform new york into a car-friendly
city by
criss-crossing the five boroughs with
highways but he encountered a problem
that he hadn't had to deal with in his
previous projects with the long island
parkway the triborough bridge and the
united nations headquarters
and his other buildings he had been
building upon land that was either
unoccupied or had previously been
dedicated to
commercial use but the plan drew for
highways cut
huge swaths right through the heart of
residential neighborhoods where
working-class new yorkers had lived for
generations
fortunately for moses the federal
government had given him the tools he
needed to
move the residents out of the way by
force since the 1930s the
federal government had been concerned
about living conditions within cities
one report from 1950 suggested that 20
of housing units in american cities fell
into the category of slums
they decided to enact legislation that
would pay municipal governments to move
residents out of neighborhoods
classified as slums and
into public housing than to demolish
nearly all structures within that
neighborhood so that the lands could be
redeveloped moses wielded the slum
clearance program
like a cudgel having added control of
public housing to his portfolio in the
years after laguardia
retired with a stroke of his pen he
could designate entire neighborhoods
self-contained ecosystems where people
lived worked and did business as being
irredeemable slums subject to the
wrecking ball
if it just so happened that these slums
happened to be in the way of a proposed
highway
well that was all the better for him one
of the most affected parts of the city
was the bronx where
the cross bronx expressway was built in
the 1950s right across the middle of the
borough 6.5 miles long and over 200 feet
wide
even those residents whose homes were
spared saw their property values lowered
dramatically thanks to the proximity
of the new highway and the cultural
heart of their neighborhood had been
permanently ripped out in the decades
that followed the bronx would become
home to some of the most distressed
neighborhoods in the united states rife
with abandoned buildings high crime and
desperate poverty there was undoubtedly
a racist undertone to
all of this as most of the neighborhoods
designated for demolition and the slum
clearance program were overwhelmingly
filled with black and latino residents
the move to the suburbs had been
called white flight since most of the
new transplants were members of the
white middle class
people of color encountered difficulties
finding banks willing to give them
mortgages and
when they did they were forced to
purchase homes in neighborhoods
designated as
suitable for members of their race a
process known as redlining
moses was certainly no stranger to
accusations of racism in the 1930s moses
spilled over 200 public playgrounds
across new york city
only two of those were in neighborhoods
with a majority of black residents
even more outrageously moses is supposed
to have ordered the city's public pools
be kept at a temperature a few degrees
cooler than normal
in an attempt to keep black new yorkers
from using them a common racial
stereotype at the time was that black
people were less able to handle the cold
than whites
[Music]
for years robert moses had rough shot
over any opposition to his projects
calling on his connections and
the vast amount of personal power that
he had accumulated to get his way
he is remarkable among public servants
for his apathy even
disdain for the people that he was
supposed to be building these public
works for he didn't need
people to like him to get what he wanted
so he didn't even attempt to court
public opinion nonetheless the master
builder's laster
started to take a hit in the late 1950s
when the first in a series of setbacks
started that would end with the
destruction of his reputation
it started with of all things a baseball
team
new york city in the 1950s was home to
three professional teams the yankees may
have been the most successful but
it was the brooklyn dodgers that were
the most beloved by their fiercely loyal
fan base but the dodgers ballpark
ebbetts field was
falling apart and the owner of the team
walter o'malley desperately wanted to
build a new stadium like all
large building projects in the city and
needed to be run through robert moses
and moses refused to allow the dodgers
permission to build their new stadium in
brooklyn he wanted a city-owned
multi-purpose stadium built
in the neighboring borough of queens
another piece of moses's expanding
empire but o'malley
refused to consider it arguing that the
dodgers were strongly associated with
brooklyn in his usual manner moses
refused to yield and o'malley rather
than giving in decided to move his team
to los angeles
adding insult to injury o'malley
persuaded horus stoneham owner of the
new york giants to move along with them
to san francisco
in an instant two out of three baseball
teams in the city
were gone shocked and horrified baseball
fans cast a bell for someone to blame
emali and stoneham were out of reach in
california so the only one left to take
the heat was moses though the city would
be awarded an expansion team a few years
later the mets who would play in moses's
desired multipurpose stadium in queens
it was a poor substitute for what they
had lost and many people continued to
resent
moses for decades afterwards over the
loss of the teams this was only a warm
up for the real trouble looming ahead by
1960 the only borough in new york that
didn't have a highway running through it
was manhattan and moses sought to change
that through his lower manhattan
expressway
a proposed 100 million dollar eight lane
highway that was to be built
right through the neighborhoods of
greenwich village soho
and little italy opposition to the
proposed highway was virulent much
stronger than any previous moses project
and far more organized they were led by
a community activist named jane jacobs
whose book the death and life of
american cities was a stinging critique
of the concepts of urban renewal and
slum clearance as
being harmful to the residents of a
neighborhood jacobs had a personal stake
in the fight against the lower manhattan
expressway where she lived was on the
chopping block
for years jacobs and moses battled each
other in the press and in public
hearings as
jacobs led mass protests against the
highway protests moses found himself
unable to swat away as he had done
previously
things came to a head in 1965 when the
mayoral election became a referendum on
the highway mayor robert wagner and the
democrats supported it while the
republicans led by congressman john
lindsay
opposed it lindsay was elected mayor and
quickly moved to kill the highway
the expressway was never built and to
date no major highway exists in
manhattan
nor is ever likely to robert moses had
overplayed his hand at last and now
lindsay decided to move against him in
the triborough bridge authority was
merged into the newly created
metropolitan transit authority its
revenues were now under control of the
city of new york
losers have been completely
outmaneuvered by lindsay and new york's
governor nelson rockefeller
and now the source of his power was gone
what was left of moses's reputation was
completely shredded in 1974 when robert
carro's seminal biography of him
entitled the power broker was published
the book which won a pulitzer prize was
an exhaustive account of moses
accomplishments
both the good and the bad it detailed
his backroom dealings his accumulation
of personal power the destruction of
neighborhoods to build highways and
his racism it also revealed one very
quirky fact about robert moses the
man who championed the need of cars over
people and that was that he never
bothered to learn to drive
moses was defiant until the very end
refusing to apologize for anything he
did he died on july
29 1981 at the age of 92 and was buried
at new york city's
woodlawn cemetery historians still argue
over the exact contribution robert moses
made to the city of new york good or bad
certainly he accomplished a lot many of
his bridges and roadways are still in
use today
vital lifelines throughout the city it
is also notable how quickly he was able
to finish
projects once he began building them
with most of his projects being
completed on time or ahead of schedule
a very rare occurrence today at the same
time the damage he did is also apparent
the
destruction of entire neighborhoods hold
blocks of historic buildings destroyed
and replaced with
sterile mega blocks public housing that
are universally reviled
his construction plans only encouraged
white flight to the suburbs and
made the resulting ghetoization of large
sections of the city that much worse as
people of color were deprived of their
homes through slum clearance programs
what's worse his model of urban planning
was followed in other american cities
particularly
in the north east and midwest it is
likely that car culture would have
prevailed in the united states even
without robert moses intervention but he
certainly made it worse
so who is robert moses the master
builder who helped shape new york city
into the modern metropolis it is today
or a bully who used public works to
increase his own power while spitefully
depriving working-class people of their
homes
as incredible as it seems well both are
true making him both a hero
and a villain at the same time one
thing's for sure though robert moses
will continue to cast a long shadow over
new york city
and will continue to do so as long as
the city's cars
rumble across his highways and over his
bridges
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you